we had how many professors were taking
money from china
oh there's a hundred at harvard at least
according to the list right now you're
saying it's a hundred
it says something like that according i
don't know if the list we have a real or
fake we're verifying yeah
okay that could be dangerously
responsible no i said it we don't know
we know that the list being used
to blackmail people has that on there
which is what's important
well in other words we don't know if
what we're looking at is both real and
fake or mixed in between
but all three of those scenarios are
very troubling dude like should i have
called security before you guys came on
like before this time well
the fbi called us the other day actually
unsolicited really
yeah well i heard they well they also
called someone else you know but
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think he committed
i think he committed voter fraud
no no no no no i thought he might i
don't know i don't know if i can talk
about it i don't know if adam's talked
about it yet but he got a bit
i don't know i just saw someone sent me
the tweet nothing to do with fraud okay
well ours was
we got a very pleasant i got a voicemail
from somebody i'm not gonna say the name
out of the blue and the voicemail was i
thought it was a prank
hey uh this is the los angeles bureau
the fbi i've never talked yet but never
called me uh or you know once advice
when we unmasked the
uh syrian electronic armies like i
remember that
they came to the office and talked to
the talk about the cto get out of here
like i don't want to talk
like and so like they call and they were
like hey we're a big fan of your work
like
i'm like uh-huh uh they didn't say that
they said
uh we heard you have a tip they said
that later when i called him back we
heard you have a tip
uh we got a tip that you have a tip that
you want to tell us
that was what they left a message on i
could play it but i don't want to i
heard from a guy that you got something
to say yeah i'm like this is not
real and so i called a lawyer i know and
they're like uh yeah you need to call
the switchboard because we've had some
issues with this
find out if they're real verify the
number and then let us know
and so i did that turns out they were
real and they work in the cyber crimes
division
uh i said i don't have any tips for you
i appreciate your kind words just watch
our videos and that'll be your tip
yeah so um i don't then i found out
later that they were actually
well we'll get into that another time
yeah okay okay earlier this year mike
pompeo said that we have been
infiltrated at all levels by
the chinese it's like he's right and
it's been it's been like that for a
while yeah that's interesting so wait
wait
i assumed you guys were you would say
something like yeah you're just saying
like oh yeah of course yeah of course
i'm sorry we've been like
looking at this for months now so i
guess i'm a little yeah
i'm like wait hold on you have a list of
compromised individuals
no no we don't have that like we're not
saying that we have the list
that guo tried to or he did well
we have a list that's been scraped
and there's i know a lot about what guo
was looking for just because i've read
like thousands of pages of depositions
and court documents at this point and
i know specifically he was looking for
he was looking for specific people
and 15 of those people had basically uh
their records are it's illegal to look
up their records because they are people
who are either
being investigated or cooperating with
the government right now so he was
trying to find
who the the compromise people were yes
well no no no
he was trying to find i wouldn't say
they're necessarily compromised
these 15 people are records protected
basically yeah
so whether those are you know a lot of
people
allege that he's a dissident hunter and
a lot of people say
he's outing chinese spies within the us
so it's sort of this question is like
are these you know is he actually
looking for people who are cooperating
with the government or is he looking for
people
who are chinese spies so that's the
really big question that we've been
investigating
and we ended up with a list
that we're working off of very slowly
you have names and we're not going to
name anything
you're smarter than that you might be
you want to be careful about it yeah
yeah
really yeah i'm excited
um but yeah so we're we're going to be
coming out with a lot more
just introducing the process of this
right importing well is the next video
up here yes oh yeah we just uploaded uh
episode two of scanner investigates
so so yeah continue sorry um and this
one specifically
some of the uh the some of the
investigating we've done a lot around
elliot brody and there's still more that
we're doing with that but
specifically we went um we went looking
into some of some of the documents
um one of which was a draft
basically a calculation of
mrap parts armored vehicles we talked a
little bit about this earlier but
basically we went to colorado to visit
an office
that used to make these kinds of deals
to authenticate a certain document
which they did for us so people can go
watch it and get a kind of bigger
picture
it's a very small part of this story
that we're going to be continuing to
report on
but yeah this spans administrations
you're saying it will starts it appears
from some of the documents that we have
it appears to start in 2015. interesting
so whether it involves obama directly we
can't say
for sure because that he's not mentioned
in in the 2015. it's a bit
it's this is this is this is difficult
to piece together i think you guys have
been like
staring at everything why don't we read
the top letter
off that pile of documents sure can we
read that yeah give us give us the
elevator
so this is literally what's on top the
first page
on a packet of documents that we got
that we can only assume or use to
leverage
something somebody wanted because it's
like what you would give to someone
to be like you're f'd right wow you're
f'd
and you better do what i say because i
got you on this so if you come after me
so it's damning information used to
blackmail somebody well it's but it's
all from
what we believe to be evidence servers
so you do the math evidence
like government servers whoa somebody
broke into government services or
someone wiped them and made copies and
gave it what
and they're publicly available which is
you'll see why oh yeah they're publicly
available you just gotta know where to
look yeah
and we figured that out so what's so
what's that so like
who's trying to do what what's that we
don't know what we're trying to do do
you want me to read the top
letter yeah let's read that yeah do it
okay we do read this in our first
episode and then we referred back to it
in our second episode but um i'll just
i'll just read it real quick and this is
an email from elliot brody to elliot
broidy
and and who is he elliot brody is the
what was his title
the former uh co-chair finance co-chair
of the art of
republican national convention and
michael cohen was as well and he got
indicted way back cameron knows that and
so was steve wynn when he got some
troubles with the
with the ladies the massages all right
you might remember
of course so they all yeah and then
elliot
brody also has an open source
intelligence company called cerseinus
which um has has gotten ordered
contracts from the government before
um so this is it's you know have you
ever sent an email to yourself just like
yeah yeah yeah so this is an email to
himself and one of several drafts that
over the next
couple years there's different
iterations of so it says fyi
i'm closing an open source intelligence
center installation in an asian country
the focus will be improving
counter-terrorism efforts against isis
the country involved has good relations
with china and the us
and offered a lucrative opportunity
china wants to extradite from the u.s
guo wing way who is
very critical of president xi jinping
and now living as a fugitive in new york
city
guo defrauded many investors including
abu dhabi for 3 billion
with elections coming up with china this
fall the chinese want him to be kept
quiet
i believe a negotiation can take place
which includes abu dhabi receiving its 3
billion back and abu dhabi extraditing
guo from the u.s to abu dhabi
later abu dhabi would allow extradition
to china i was told china would pay us
and if the facts are indeed correct i
assume abu dhabi would feel obliged to
pay a fee as well
please check facts on your end thank you
and then this next part says
this information is strictly for you and
mbz
only you know who embezzy is who's nbc
okay
well you should look him up what'd you
say just
be z yeah so nbc i want to get his uh
his title correct
um but he's he's a very uh he's a
really prominent political figure in his
muhammad bin zayed yeah
i didn't want to butcher his name they
call it i already did it uh so muhammad
oh yeah
yeah which country is it uh so he's
crowned prince of the emirate of abu
dhabi
interesting interesting yeah wasn't he
wasn't he involved in the recent peace
agreements with trump and uh
yes so this information is strictly for
you and mbz only the asian country
involved
is malaysia they are in dire need of
close relationship and cooperation with
the u.s
i conveyed three important ways for
malaysia to cooperate and
assist u.s one cooperate closely on
counter-terrorism efforts against isis
al-qaeda etc
to cooperate on north korea given their
long their special long-term
relationship
they can do much to help and three
cooperate and act in a more balanced way
with regard to china
u.s this is very real along with one
items one to three above which i
requested this additional item was
offered to me to sweeten the deal
opera the the deal uh open source
intelligence center deal
i am working i'm working on which is 42
million dollars per year and already
agreed to
as you know they are they have a they
have big legal issues from their
sovereign fund and 1mdb
mdb development fund which we mentioned
a little earlier
malaysia recently settled abu dhabi for
1.2 billion in debt repayment
malaysia is receiving assistance from
china in fact they received assistance
to pay the settlement with abu dhabi
malaysia wants me to assist them and
they stressed china
as additional detail deals for me i told
them usa first and i cannot and will not
do defense or intel business with china
they told me to get involved on guo
which is not sensitive to national
security of u.s
but it is the irony of that last
statement i would say it is a little bit
a little tiny bit yeah a little bit uh
so yes so so
what's the gist of this email it's it is
hard to follow
it's very simple there is a crime caper
and it's more interesting than any james
bond movie you've ever seen it's just
you know people took guo took two
sovereign wealth funds so think of it
like
two hedge funds of five billion or a
piece
these numbers aren't correct but think
about it that way so simplify it slam
them together
one of them was a 1mdb and well let's
put it this way he slammed
multiple funds together and the sparks
that flew off
all these people tried to get collect
right and then to absolve themselves of
the crime because it was an
international scandal
after trump came in they tried to
approach various parties to get it
dropped
right and we have all the documents and
the contracts between people like
what dropped like the criminal
investigation criminal investigation on
the u.s side of the 1mdb scandal because
other international investigations were
happening already right right
wolf of wall street remember wolf of
wall street leo dicaprio kind of got
caught up with it that was the only
headline in america that america cares
about right it's
the movies and jlo tech was a executive
producer
on that film was well known and loved
throughout hollywood
he was on the hot seat so he hired
actually brody's wife
robin brody who's an entertainment
attorney have all the contracts right
75 million she was promised plus a five
uh i don't know
what the retainer was but a fixed
retainer if they could
get it dropped within or get the matter
resolved and the matter was the wolf of
wall street so you got to do the math
there
and that's all said and it was like an
eight-page contract
75 million if it was dropped within a
hundred and half a year and then
you know 50 if it was a year plus the
retainer i mean these are small numbers
obviously jayla tech was
one of the supposed alleged architects
behind this and hasn't come back to the
states in a while
uh supposedly uh living in china sort of
the architect of the deal where they
slam the things together well he took
he took a lot of the money from the 1mdb
fund and spent it on things like
a yacht and jewelry and you know his
girlfriend at the time who was like some
hollywood uh model or model yeah she was
a model
um uh she had to return something like
six or eight billion dollars or a
million dollars yeah i'm sorry
million dollars worth of jewelry i was
like whoa yeah yeah
jewelry yeah used to bigger numbers
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you